warning this video contains cold Geass
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
man who else is excited for season 3 now
kircheis and then a pretty definitive
note at least in terms of the overall
plot and many people whether they feel
that at the end the lush is dead or
alive felt that the ending itself was
pretty good so now that we know there's
going to be a third season the real
question is where do they go from here
what happens next what happens in season
3 part of the problem is that Code Geass
season 2 or r2 already featured a huge
worldwide conflict super-powered mecca's
a giant flying fortress called the
Damocles and weapons of mass destruction
known as the flail so the question is
where can they go from here every good
anime likes to raise the stakes in each
new season just think of Gurren Lagann
where they begin trapped in a cave and
end up saving the entire universe so
where can the writers of code geass go
from a huge worldwide conflict the first
thing you're going to need to do is hire
some really good writers and the second
thing they're probably gonna be thinking
about is aliens okay not those aliens
let me show you what I mean in Code
Geass it is implied that there once was
an ancient civilization of being super
zest code and it was these beings who
created the eighth thought elevators
that are scattered around the globe in
which Charles uses to activate the
Ragnarok connection since they were able
to create these structures of great
power
clearly the civilization was very
advanced and powerful and it kind of
reminds me of the Atlantis myth in our
own world but what happened to these
ancient beings who were these ancient
beings could it be that they were
ancient aliens take a look at this clip
from episode 1 of Code Geass when the
louche first gets his Geass power from
sea to this flashes by a bit quickly so
I'm going to slow this down
check out this frame see here you can
see an ancient civilization of beings
who have cold you can see the code sign
on their foreheads and you can see by
the way they're dressed that they're
clearly part of some ancient
civilization that is not familiar to us
look at this next frame we can see a
planet why did they show us what looks
like a foreign planet could it be that
they're trying to tell us and give us a
brief hint that these beings this
civilization comes from another planet
or perhaps that they have colonized
multiple planets and built these devices
these thought elevators on all of these
different planets I'm actually a fiction
writer myself and I read a lot of
stories and I write a lot of stories and
if I was writing this third season of
cold yes I would want to explore more
fully this ancient civilization where
are they now
do they have powers we still don't know
about are they aliens who colonize
multiple planets and do they possess
technology that can make them a
brand-new challenge and threat to the
world of copias and a new reason for
Lelouch to resurface you might have
heard of our key to the Exile which is
an OVA or spin-off of Code Geass that is
supposed to take place between the first
and second seasons now in Akito the
exiled episode 3 we can see that c2 is
part of a Geass order and that she
offers a Geass contract to Layla who is
the main character of Akito the exiled
near the end of the episode we see
another immortal which appear as an
apparition to one of the characters and
she tells him the following all that
matters to us is that the balance of
space-time is maintained we do not care
who becomes king of this world this
clearly implies that the power these
beings with code possess stretches far
beyond just our world in the last
episode of Akito the exiled episode 5
this same being with code appears to
Layla and she tells her that she and
others like her are actually
representations of the collective
consciousness so she says that she is
not really a human at all and then in
fact humans can only possess a small
fragment of what is the true power of
Geass
she says that humans cannot even imagine
the full extent of Geass power this
makes me think that perhaps these
original beings with code this ancient
civilization became so advanced that
they moved beyond physical forms and
became representations of pure
consciousness kind of like
the anti spirals in Gurren Lagann we
can't know any of this for sure because
we don't know if Akito the exiled is
actually going to be canon to what
happens in season 3 we don't know if
it's going to be relevant but we can
just look at it for some clues to what
might happen and if we have Lelouch and
our protagonists facing a powerful race
of ancient beings with code I think that
would be a very cool way to raise the
stakes you know if these beings are so
advanced they've moved beyond physical
form and they have powers of Geass that
we cannot even imagine then it's
definitely going to challenge and test
the power of Lelouch it is also
important to note that Akito the exiled
has many problems with character
development and plot and we definitely
need better writers for season three or
Code Geass but some things that are key
to the Exile does well is the animation
and the powerful action sequences which
actually include jazz music and it
reminds me of kind of Cowboy Bebop with
mecca's and it's pretty cool Aki to the
Exile doesn't reduce some cool new
concepts which might come up again in
code geass season 3 including new types
of nightmares which move in unique ways
some of them move like a spider for
example or like a horse so that's very
cool I have to say and the concept of
launching nightmares into space with a
rocket is also introduced and this is
used in order to land the nightmares by
surprise into enemy territory so again
we're going into space and even in Aki
to the exiled and this might come back
again in code geass season 3 in fact I'm
willing to bet that it will so yeah in
terms of the potential villains for code
geass season 3 I would look at this
ancient advanced civilization of beings
with code and it might turn out that
they're actually an alien civilization
with advanced powers and technology the
other important point that I want to
talk about is the fact that Lelouch is
said to be coming back as the main
character in season 3 in my previous
video on Code Geass season 3 and you can
check it out the link is in the
description I argued that Lelouch is
still alive at the end of Code Geass
because he was able to take Charles's
code away from him so Lelouch is alive
because he has code and he is now an
immortal being just like c2 however now
that Lelouch possesses code there are
still two separate possibilities for his
Geass power
and I want to talk about those right now
the first possibility is that now that
he possesses cold Lelouch can no longer
use his Geass power the same way as c2
and Charles could no longer use their
Geass power after they received cold
even if this is the case Lelouch would
still be an important character because
don't forget that someone with code can
actually give Geass to other people so
this means that Lelouch could
potentially mentor a new generation of
Geass users and he could be the
mastermind behind them the second
possibility is actually something I did
not consider until a couple of people
pointed it out in the comments to my
previous video on Lelouch so thank you
guys very much for that and basically
this argument states that the reason c2
and Charles could no longer use their
Geass power once they got cold is
because the people that gave them their
Geass power in the first place the none
and v2 were dead now because luce didn't
receive his Geass power from Charles he
actually received it from c2 and she is
still alive which means that their
contract is still valid
this means that Lelouch could actually
possess code and Geass at the same time
and maybe that's the point of the title
of the anime Code Geass this is a really
cool theory and a big thank you again to
everyone who pointed it out to me and if
this is really the case if Lelouch
possesses both code and Geass that means
that he will be a really powerful being
in season 3 but that also means that
it's gonna need some really powerful
opponents some really powerful enemies
at any rate it's gonna be really fun to
see what Code Geass season 3 has in
store for us and I'm definitely excited
I can't wait so yeah guys I hope you
like this video and please let me know
what some of your theories are about
what's going to happen in season 3 let
me know down in the comments because I'm
really interested in what you think and
if you did enjoy this video give it a
like give it a share and be sure to
subscribe for more videos about Code
Geass season 3 and until next time see a
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]